we don't need to talk about blaze oh my
god
but Jordan is back someone's gonna be
calling me daddy by the end of this and
we're turning on Hannah
it's the ultimate like slap in the face
this is your bachelor in paradise
episode 3 recap grab your glasses it's
time for roses and rosy hi you guys i'm
lauren zima and look at this cool
tropical cup oh not just my shirt wow
I'm on point
paradise is on point as a show the
people in Paradise are not on point as
people oh this umbrellas gonna be a
problem don't fall in my rose say don't
fall my rose they don't fall apart
that's what people tell themselves in
Paradise this season okay
Oh everybody it was another good one
wasn't it I am addicted to paradise this
season do you think it's the best season
ever let me know in the comments below
one weekend I'm already given it the
stamp of yes personally welcome to the
first rose ceremony of paradise let's
get to it so everything is up for change
and evolution and different vibes this
season in paradise you know people are
hooking up before paradise people are
setting up lies before paradise and
Chris Harrison is saying Dylan ga'head
at the rose ceremony
Dylan good he's like good this is a
dumpster fire of it so if I've ever seen
one so Dylan get head good I loved it Oh
Hannah so Dylan still gives Hannah his
rose despite all the Blake stuff Dylan
stand strong and we stand Dylan I guys
is Dylan the new Tyler see I'm sorry was
that blasphemous I mean he's not making
those same Tyler C signature speeches
but God he's a good guy and I am digging
Dylan deep in fallen hard
okay Taoiseach had said that she would
not accept Blake's rose but she did did
you judge it for that on the one hand
girls stayed true to your word on the
other hand girl wants to stay in
paradise you know I don't blame her
and Blake seems to have not given her
the full picture of his past when taking
her on that date so she put all her eggs
in the Blake basket and she wasn't
really told the full truth about what
else was in the basket or even the shape
of the basket even what kind of basket
it was so I think it's fair for
Taoiseach to take the rose take that
rose so after the rose ceremony we say
goodbye to some alumni and Elise
viviana maybe if I would have hook up
with Blake I would have still been here
you're barely here but I'd like both of
you they're both great I don't know why
people don't like that why can't analyse
and maybe I ought to find anyone who do
you guys if them with let me know in the
comments below what's up Jordan good to
see you welcome back thanks
but another alum Jordan Campbell is back
oh I do have a soft spot for Jordan he's
just funny you know and drink every time
Jordan just says some signature weird
Jordan crap your boys salty peppered
season I'm looking for the bone depth it
comes with a marriage engagement
somebody grabbed it on my chest if you
didn't wash your hands so establishments
come down sometimes we need to renovate
bring something better in
a little backsplash all right heads up
on my day Jordans hi Oh a curveball Anna
thinks Jordan is cute
[Music]
I mean I don't know how many times I'm
gonna have to remind out of this you
have Dylan that becomes the question of
this episode is Hanna a player what do
you guys think let me know in the
comments below
drink for every time somebody turns on
Hanna this app it happens
she knows what she's doing I don't trust
her anna is toying with Dillon's
emotions I thought she was kind of
innocent in all this but I feel as
though she's had her hand in a lot of
the drama she's a freaking player and
Hanna's at the center of it she's not
innocent in any of it
Hanna you want to go talk Jordan comes
in he wastes literally no time he's like
Hanna I have a date card you want to
talk let's go talk right now and but
then the discussions that Jordan is
having turned into reliving all the
Blake stuff even though
Blake is actually interested in chase
nobody's also interested in
when everyone imitation guys I don't
know are you already burnt out I ended
up taking Blake on the date and it
wasn't romantic it was just something
happened before they don't need it spot
right here my bags I don't need anymore
Blake downs but I do need Blake dancing
in the pool with literally no one
watching him and by the way Hannah you
got Blake doing that and you got Dylan
over here using words like incessant yes
all day
good-looking kind supportive smart why
do we need
by the way drink for every person who's
into Hanna I mean she is the babe of a
bachelor in paradise right now hot
commodity Santos if I take you away
Wow hit herself lucky she's done so
Jordan
[Music]
under that was gonna happen I think if
anyone deserves a shot it's you I think
if anyone else's understood me
Jordan asks Hannah on the date and I
don't want to see the day between Hannah
and Jordan I just don't I just want to
get her together I've become like the
mom I'm like their mom and I'm like you
two are gonna work okay you two are good
so honey you stick with him and my dear
you stick with her okay okay drink every
time that Jordan calls paradise his
Beach yeah you ready for paradise ready
it's my beach the mayor of paradise is
back welcome to my Beach everybody
what's up this is my Beach
I just walked into paradise well my
beach this is my Beach oh really
connecting with Dylan yeah and I'm
trying to figure out where Blake and I
stand
and I think if you would have come
earlier and then oh my gosh this
franchise is always the gift that keeps
on giving
Hannah very nicely rejects Jordan from
the date cheers to that are we
progressing
are we moving forward as people are we
already growing here in bachelor in
paradise I know you you are better than
this you know
hammer it out one by one oh and then
Jordan you know the veteran that he is
decides to tell Blake what's up to tell
him that he needs to figure things out
cheers to that are we evolving are we
progressing here in paradise we're
probably not I love Dylan
he is really into you and
whereas like I don't know what he wants
every day you know but a little more
wisdom Demi is talking to Hannah and
she's like I love Dylan why don't you
love Dylan oh and I looked at me for
saying she loves Dylan I also love Demi
so much love so much wisdom
Dylan's so we're clearly a better guy
yes let's finish our wine on that note
[Music]
how much does this glass hold I'm about
this class and it's gonna be up to my
standards of volume oh it's deep though
[Music]
I need a new sauna I'm going on a date
with Jordan like what
so Jordan and nicole end up going on a
date and I just don't think there's
really a romantic connection here so
it's hard for me to care even though
Blake is actually interested in chase
nobody's also interested in Hannah and
then the Blake stuff comes up again I
mean it's really hard for me to care and
then everything changes what the real
reason ever
[Music]
Jorge our bachelor in paradise bartender
of yesteryear ziplines in and tells
Jorden and Nicole that he lost his
virginity here in the channel because at
least the specific spot of this jungle
is what I lost my virginity no no any
briefs a lot of good memories to me and
I wanted you to have a good it's like
the story was good enough on its own the
Jordans laugh is the best thing ever
oh God
and you know then Jordan pop some
champagne and he says it's his favorite
and I'm like me - Jordan and you're one
of my favorites and I adore you I always
here last year and I left very happy a
couple months later it got crazy
oh but things do get deep Jordan talks
about his split from Jenna last season
Jenna and I split the day literally I
proposed on TV we ended it and and he
reveals that they broke up later that
day the day that he proposed I knew a
lot about that situation but I did not
know that it is dark babe I love girls
swimsuit thank you yeah I should have
want my cheetah shirt the the jungle
couple you know we forgot about cam but
cams here and cam is talking to Kailyn
and he's written something for her kinda
long
but just bear with me and it's not a
wrap guess what
today is a new day and I know that it's
gonna be a great one
do you know why
why what is it is it a haiku because
you're still here in paradise smiley
face I like my lower to live in your
jalapeno Rita spice still lingered and
brought me such joy oh wait now he's
talking about licking his lips
is it a romance know that I'll always
defend you and be your biggest cam fan a
bad one and he reads whatever that
Odyssey was to her and then tells her
you can keep that for later babe thank
you
Kayla's probably thinking I'm good yeah
cam says that he is 100 percent certain
he's going to propose to Kaelyn 100%
certain and always be with her Oh Lord
and then Mike is here and Mike's always
a breath of fresh is me I mean he looks
good and he's got his beautiful thick
might smile and he grabs Kayla would you
like to hear yes and she's like how are
you and he's like blessed
I'm blessed are you what a positive
response fine note is James still here
did Jane leave and I missed it well she
cutted the rose ceremony I don't see
Jane sorry shouldn't be John Paul Jones
throw up Oxley attractive T but our
conversation to me is what
[Music]
so Kalyn it might go on a date and you
know it drink for another good vocab
moment Mike says flabbergasted well I'm
just glad we're not seeing clarity
anymore I'm very interested in Katie
she's just beautiful you never know
what's gonna happen in Paradise which is
what I love about this show Will's goes
and talks to Katie and he's just kind of
like trying to get to network you know
you just chill he's Will's he's like a
pretty even guy and I feel like you
deserve in the world and he deserves
someone taking on a date every single
night you're here he's like a smooth
pond he's just he's even and he's still
and he's calm and Katie throws our rock
in that flemeth that creates a ripple
effect of her own tears Katie what is
going on she is crying too wills and
then she is crying in her ITM and Katie
this is basically a first date I don't
know what's happening this is like a guy
came up to you talk to you in a bar and
you're having this reaction is Katie
okay you know drink for every time we
have to do a wellness check this season
last week we were doing wellness checks
on Blake now we might need to do a
wellness check on Kate II hey guys it's
me I would only normally vlog in this
condition for a breaking news situation
but very nice moves fast and this is
important I forgot to make a joke about
Blake falling into a rock
oh he's okay I mean booboo literally hit
rock bottom that's all but couples are
starting to happen now you know
katieandchris do we like it i me know in
the comments below
I feel confident how I feel about her
and I feel confident that she's God is
telling her and Blake has gone from
Blake downs to shakedowns he is going to
zero in on Hannah
he says he's all-in but he does it in an
interesting way he says he's all-in on
Hannah and because he's all-in on Hannah
he wants to dance with her doing to have
some fun you know so I wanted to dance
with you there's no music Blake you know
we're on the beach and I don't know how
safe that is like for your ankles that
you're doing these swing dancing moves
in the sand and again there's no music
would you guys be into this oh and then
it gets really dark because Christina
says that he did that to her too good
resting I remember that move apparently
the swing dancing is his move
I want to try a new one Blake is too
swing dancing as Jed is too guitar no
bun from vocab to just kind of a
literary lesson that things are of
course in paradise taking off Hanna and
Blake are kissing Johanna honey you need
to what was my mom voice okay you need
to unlock your lips Hanna you need to
move away from Blake that my mom has
turned southern look like I leave
southern I'm from Chicago
okay so Hanna and Blake are kissing and
Dylan is talking to Derek and now is
Dylan turning on Hanna makes me wonder
like has she been 100%
what do you guys think Hannah should be
doing obviously she should be doing
it all is so clear it always be clear
here to us the viewer we weren't at the
moment what do you guys think why is
Hannah holding on to Blake let me know
in the comments below let's finish up
this rose' for our show
I should be like I should write a haiku
since that's what scam was trying to do
okay here is the haiku that cam was
trying to write for Kaylin I coos if you
remember from English class are broken
up in syllables 575 please date me
someone I rap and it is fun I want Mary
now
[Music]
can we wish you all the best
truly seems like a sweet guy is just a
little loss right okay thank you guys so
much for watching I love you love you
love you tell me all of your thoughts on
the season of Paradise again is it the
best ever are we all ready degreeing
that after three episodes let me know in
the comments below I'm on cameo if you
want a personal message from me and
we'll be back with another episode based
on Tuesday's episode love you bye
[Music]
[Music]